(upbeat music)
- All right.
Welcome, everyone.
As I said and mentioned a moment ago,
my name's Alfred Guy
and I work in the Poorvu Center
as the Director of Undergraduate Tutoring.
I also oversee the writing
requirement in Yale College,
and I teach courses in
English and humanities.
I'm gonna give about
a two minute introduction to this panel,
and then we're gonna get
right to the faculty speakers.
Within a week of
ChatGPT-3.5 being released
on November 30th,
the Poorvu Center started to
get questions from faculty
about its implications for teaching,
because this technology is
potentially so disruptive,
which I don't mean as pejorative,
for teaching and learning,
we all have questions,
and so it made sense to
gather people to talk.
We're very grateful to the faculty panel
for agreeing to launch this conversation,
which we expect will also
continue well after this event.
The format for the event is
that each faculty panelist
will speak for five minutes
about their ideas
for how AI generative writing
might affect teaching and learning.
After the panelists,
we will have time to hear some questions
that were submitted in advance
and some questions
that people generate during
this meeting via chat.
We may get more questions
than we can use today,
but we will use them to
shape future programming
and resources that we
build about these issues.
I wanna welcome Nisheeth Vishnoi
from the Computer Science Department.
Professor Vishnoi is
the A. Bartlett Giamatti
Professor of Computer Science
and a co-founder
of the Computation and Society Initiative
at Yale University.
He studies the foundations of computation
and his research spends several areas
of theoretical computer science,
optimization, and machine learning.
He's also interested in
understanding nature and society
from a computational viewpoint.
Here his current focus includes studying
the emergency of intelligent...
Excuse me, that's a Freudian slip.
Studying the emergence
of intelligent behavior
and ethical problems
at the interface of artificial
intelligence and society.
Professor Vishnoi, welcome.
- Thank you, Alfie.
Yes, I guess it was a Freudian slip.
We are in some kind of
an emergency, I guess,
and I'm very glad
to see so many people
interested in this event.
So I'll keep my remarks
brief and to the point.
I guess we are all here
to talk about ChatGPT,
which is one of the latest in the line
of what are called
generative models in AI.
So these are algorithms
which can learn about things
such as images, or in this case, texts.
and are able to do
conversations with human beings,
and I guess what has caught
our attention here is
the ability to have these kinds
of very non-trivial
interactions with human beings,
and that's caused a lot of concern.
So from my point of view,
I think coming to the point
of how it impacts the
teaching and learning,
I think the first point
I would like to say is
that it'll add to showing us the gap
between learning and evaluation.
I guess, as a university,
our goal is to ensure
that our students learn,
but how we check
whether they have learned
these three evaluations,
and I guess the concern that arises is
how students are going to use this tool
or tools such as this,
which are likely to come in future
to aid in their evaluation.
So my prognosis is that in the short-term,
I would imagine that
this gap will increase,
but I think it does give
us a very nice opportunity
to think about how we can
reduce the misalignment
between learning and evaluation.
The second point I would make is
about how it can impact the power
and biases already present in society.
We don't have to take
the example of ChatGPT,
but even previous tools
from natural language
processing and computer vision
have illustrated
that these algorithms can
propagate certain types of biases,
enabling or increasing the power
of certain groups in society,
and I believe these kinds
of tools like ChatGPT
will work both ways.
On the one hand,
they will level the playing field.
For example,
let's say, if English is
not your natural language
and you would like to compose a nice email
to your professor or to whoever,
then you can put in a
partially phrased email,
or not necessarily the finished email,
and get a polished version of it,
and you can imagine these kinds of users,
which will reduce the gap
between different groups
who, for whatever reason,
have to spend more resources coming up
with the same outcome.
On the other hand,
given that these are generative models,
which are learning from existing data,
which data doesn't come from vacuum,
it comes from the society that we live in,
it will for sure propagate
the bias that already exists,
and I think things have to be done
to check these kinds of biases.
I guess, one of the things
that might be also of immediate concern is
that if students start using ChatGPT,
how are we going to check and enforce
whether there is some kind of cheating
in some way or the other?
This probably applies to exams
which have a more written component to it,
and I believe that that's
something that ChatGPT itself is,
or open AI itself is thinking about,
how to include watermarking,
which is a technique
from computer science,
which allows you to spot
if certain answers are...
Have been generated using this
software or this algorithm.
Yeah, so I think these are the key points
and I will pass it on to the others,
and I'm curious to hear
what my other colleagues and
audience would have to say.
Thank you.
- That's wonderful.
Thank you so much, Professor Vishnoi.
So our second panelist is
gonna be Brian Scassellati,
also from the Computer Science Department.
Professor Scassellati is the
A. Bartlett Giamatti professor
of computer science, cognitive science,
and mechanical engineering.
He builds robots that help people
by providing social and cognitive support,
including systems that teach social skills
to children with autism,
systems that help adults cope
with anxiety and depression,
and systems that tutor children
in challenging subjects.
His work not only produces useful tools,
but also helps us to learn about the ways
in which people understand
social behavior,
categorize things as
animate and inanimate,
and collaborate with each other.
So thank you and welcome
Professor Scassellati.
- Thanks very much, Alfie,
and thanks, Nisheeth,
for giving us a really good
start and foundation for this.
I guess my first message
was really inspired by a lot
of the teachers and educators
that I spoke to recently,
and it's simply this,
don't panic, we've been here before.
In 1966, Joe Weizenbaum wrote
this program called ELIZA,
that, at the time,
was thought of as this
incredible new thing,
but even Weizenbaum admitted
it was a very, very simple program.
All it did was take in
a line of typed text
and look for certain patterns,
and replace one set of words with another.
So if you said to ELIZA,
"I'm really worried about my father,"
it would pick out the word
"worried" and "my father,"
and it would write back,
and say, "Why are you
worried about your father?"
And it followed this school of thought
that's now identified as
Rogerian psychotherapy,
where the idea was to mirror back
without adding anything
to the conversation,
and at the time,
many people thought of this
as almost a solution to natural language.
People were worried
that this was going to
replace them in their jobs.
The Association for
Psychotherapy wrote Weizenbaum
and begged him to get rid of the program.
Weizenbaum's own assistant he had to fire,
because she did nothing other
than talk to ELIZA all day.
Even serious natural language researchers,
this brand new field that had just begun,
some of them wrote
that probably they were
only a few years away
from solving language,
whatever that meant.
We've seen this before
and there's always a lot of hype,
and excitement that comes when
new technologies come out.
Now that's not to say
that ChatGPT isn't an
amazing piece of technology,
but we've faced these problems before.
In 2015, I taught the first
version of CS50 here at Yale
and we had almost 425
students in the class.
I think it is
still the largest engineering
course we've ever taught here,
and when we did,
we realized that between 400 students here
and 800 students at Harvard,
we were gonna have problems
with academic honesty,
and along the way we developed some tools,
and we used some existing
tools out there to help us,
because there were already at the time,
huge databases of code,
and even completed assignments
that were available online,
not to mention forums like Stack Exchange,
where you could post a question
and someone would helpfully
give you a piece of code
as an answer,
or even automated systems like Copilot
that would write code along with you.
So how could we distinguish
these automatically generated
or just plain plagiarized
pieces from everything else?
Now, for us, at the time,
one of the key things was we
looked at the white space,
that is the difference
between spaces, and tabs, and line fields
in the code that was written,
and in fact, it was very
easy to find the students
who had copied things directly,
because those patterns were very obvious
and very easy to spot.
That's not gonna be the same with ChatGPT.
It's not gonna be as easy
for us to go in and look,
and say, "Are there the
right number of spaces
in between that period and
the start of the next line?"
But there are patterns.
I think overall,
the second message I would wanna
bring today is just to say,
in a way, this is a challenge.
It is a challenge for us as educators,
but I think it's actually
a very good challenge,
because it's forcing us
to look for creative and original thought,
and not just what these systems do,
which is just a rewording
and a regurgitation of the
sources that they have been fed.
I think that in the whole,
this will make us a stronger
and better organization,
a way in which we can train our students
to be more robust thinkers,
but it will be more effort along the way.
So there is a challenge
out there for us right now.
How do we look at the way
that we take these written submissions
and evaluate them,
not just based on how they
can replay sources from us,
but rather look for that
creative and original thought.
Thanks very much.
- Thank you so much.
That was wonderful.
Thank you.
All right, so I'm gonna
introduce Laura Wexler,
our next speaker.
Professor Wexler is
the Charles H. Farnam
Professor of American Studies
and Women's, Gender,
and Sexuality Studies,
the acting co-chair of the
Yale Public Humanities Program,
and a founding member of FemTechNet,
the Feminist Technology Network.
A scholar of photography
and visual culture,
she is the founding PI,
principal investigator,
of Photogrammar.
an interactive, multi-layer geospatial map
of the more than 170,000 photographs
and metadata taken and collected
by the Farm Security Administration
between 1935 and 1944
and housed at the Library of Congress.
She's interested in all aspects
of the digital learning space.
So thank you and welcome,
Professor Wexler.
- Oh, thank you very much.
I'm so pleased that this is happening
and thank you, Alfie,
and Jenny Frederick, and the Poorvu Center
for allowing us to have this opportunity
for opening this discussion
together as a community,
and I thank my two colleagues
whose remarks were very much, I think,
on point and really helpful.
It does seem to me also
that we've been here before,
cell phones and computers, Wikipedia,
Google search, spell check.
Just in the last few years in the academy,
there have been a lot of changes
that have been said
to herald the end of
things as we know them,
and that we had to put
up defensive barriers
in our classrooms against them,
as somehow I have a contrarian feeling
that leads me all the way
back to a very ancient story
that I wanna share with you today.
So this is just pieces of this story.
A long time ago,
a famous teacher told this
story to one of his pupils.
He was talking about an Egyptian god
who had invented writing
and was trying to tell the king of thieves
about how he invented writing,
and he said,
"It will make the Egyptians wiser
and will improve their memory.
I have discovered a potion
for memory and for wisdom,"
and the king replied,
"Oh, most expert, Theuth,
one man can give birth to
the elements of an art,
but only another can judge
how they can benefit or harm
those who will use them,"
and now, since you are
the father of writing,
your affection for it
has made you describe its effects
as the opposite of what they really are.
In fact, writing will
introduce forgetfulness
into the soul of those who learn it.
They will not practice using their memory,
because they will put
their trust in writing,
which is external
and depends on signs
that belong to others.
Instead of trying to remember
from the inside, completely on their own.
You have not discovered
a potion for remembering,
but for reminding.
You provide your students
with the appearance of wisdom,
not with its reality.
Your invention will enable them
to hear many things without
being properly taught,
and they will imagine that
they have come to know much,
while, for the most part,
they will know nothing
and they will be difficult
to get along with,
since they will merely appear to be wise
instead of really being so."
This is, of course, Socrates,
and this is the "Phaedrus,"
the dialogue that Plato wrote down,
because Socrates wouldn't use writing
to write his own teachings down.
Your students will not
learn from the inside
and they will be hard to get along with,
because they will imagine
that they know something
when actually they know nothing,
and what this is,
I think at base,
underneath the sensationalism
of all the headlines,
is the college essay over?
Is the college class over?
Is the college education over?
Are college instructors over?
Is this over?
Which sells papers.
That's why we're being
asked these questions.
At base, this is very much the same fear.
If you commit learning to writing,
students will not know from the inside,
but what I want to focus on
about this very interesting,
ancient dialogue is
that Socrates' solution
does not lie in a clever assignment,
or a brilliant prompt,
or a way of keeping the collaborative AI
out of the space of the classroom.
It actually relies on
person to person presence
between people learning together,
teachers and students,
so that the writing is
merely a reminder of the embodied, real,
I, thou, another
philosopher would've said,
knowledge that's being
communicated in the classroom,
and to me, I would like to focus
on this aspect of the challenge
and the opportunity that is before us,
because it's very exciting
what the AI can now do,
and very exciting to learn.
It's not that we're being confronted
with the strange, alien
presence of a computer
that will now take over our classrooms.
We're actually being confronted
with a new aspect of ourselves,
patterns at scale
that we've never been able
to understand about ourselves before.
This is the challenge.
It will certainly change what
we know and what we can learn,
but I don't believe it will change
the very basic key to knowledge
that Socrates was trying to explain,
person to person excitement
about transmitting learning together.
So I see this as an immense opportunity
to discover with our students together
what we can do with this new technology.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Professor Wexler.
Thank you very much.
So rich already.
I have so many thoughts and feelings.
Our next panelist is Justin
Farrell from sociology.
So Justin Farrell is a
professor of sociology
in the Yale School of the Environment.
He studies American culture
with a focus on social
class, moral conflict,
epistemology, and the environment.
He blends ethnographic
field work in rural areas
with large scale computational techniques
from network science and machine learning.
So welcome and thank
you, Professor Farrell.
- Thank you so much.
It's great to be here.
Before I talk specifically about
the ways that I'm responding
to AI in my teaching,
I wanna say a few words
about knowledge production,
about ethics, and the
mission of higher education,
to echo Dr. Wexler's comments as well.
So allow me to be very
big picture for a moment.
I know it might sound trite,
I guess, maybe not,
but before we start to devise
fixes or technical solutions,
I think we need to think harder
about the kind of culture that exists
in the modern university
and how that affects the role of AI today.
All fields from the medical
and planetary sciences
to the social sciences and humanities,
they rely on agreed upon
rules and practices,
educational virtues that are
necessary for truth seeking,
and they favor disagreement, argument,
conflict, continual
openness to new evidence,
and I would ask, "Are we
cultivating these virtues
and how can we do better?"
And I think this needs to
be part of the conversation.
For example, in what ways
are teaching and learning,
even in the most technical fields,
captive to instrumental thinking?
Are we limiting our students
with surface level or
instrumentalized visions
of learning and knowledge production.
These issues are really big
and they're ancient as
Dr. Wexler just showed,
and I'm not naive to the
social and economic pressures,
but all fields from econ to medicine,
to business, sociology, computer science
can, in their own way,
instill values of a liberal education
that I think will combat a culture
whereby cheating feels
necessary or even justified,
because only education
can nurture a culture of truth seeking,
of scientific reasoning,
and ethical engagement needed
to inoculate individuals
from falling prey to the misuse of AI.
So as AI continues to improve,
I think professors and teachers need
to bring a renewed seriousness
to education itself,
and Poorvu is a big help in this,
so that we might build wisdom
and character in our students
as they write papers,
as they do experiments,
visit the archives, write computer code,
and just become producers of knowledge.
So I hope all this can be part
of the conversation as well.
So more concretely, how is
AI influencing my teaching?
I just have two points on this.
One way I think it's
becoming more common is
subjecting these AI tools to critique.
So I teach a field course this semester
and when ChatGPT came online,
I think it was in late
November, early December,
I added to my syllabus
that students must investigate
their research question
using ChatGPT,
but also critique it,
and learning through critique,
as we have always done in the academy.
I identify kind of two
pathways for critique,
but there there are more.
One would obviously be
to critique the accuracy
of ChatGPT essays,
relative to their research question.
A lot of my students have
on the ground research
questions for this class.
It's very applied in a lot of ways.
So, are the answers
that it gives accurate?
Are they misleading, unethical?
What is missing?
What does it get right or partially right?
The second critique would be
the eventual commodification
or current commodification of the tool.
So I see this as an opportunity
or an empirical question for
research for my students.
As we all know,
commercial interests monetize AI
and cash in on these algorithms
that can be destructive to social life.
So I'm pushing students to consider
how the production of knowledge
from tools like ChatGPT
might parallel similar developments
where algorithms can
profit from disinformation,
from hyperbole or extremism,
or historically,
how is this similar to or
different from previous examples,
or even pre-digital campaigns
like smoking or climate denial
where powerful commercial
interests influence the production
and dissemination of knowledge
and information to the public.
Secondly, other than critiquing,
one way that that I think is,
perhaps more effective might be
prioritizing experiential learning,
and keeping with this course
I'm teaching this semester,
I try to get students out of the classroom
as much as possible
into the field using
project-based teaching
that I think offer tools for discovery,
tools for cognitive engagement, obviously,
but also social belonging,
and often with people
outside the university
who are very different than them,
and so part of this
course over spring break,
we go to an area where I do research,
which is the greater
Yellowstone ecosystem,
and I bring my students
to Wyoming and Montana.
Now they have these research projects,
but they're paired with
local NGOs oftentimes,
and so they develop a relationship
and while they're using
ChatGPT for their projects,
they cultivate these virtues
of social responsibility,
of personal investment in their projects
and responsibility to their
on the ground partners,
and so I think, at the present moment,
this type of encounter
and these type of experiences
are difficult to replicate even for AI.
So I'll leave it there.
Thank you.
- That's great.
Thank you so much, Professor Farrell,
and so we'll hear from one more panelist
and then we have some questions
that have been coming in.
Amazing questions by the way, people.
You keep sending them in.
Okay, so we're gonna hear
from Professor Khawaja,
Noreen Khawaja from the
Religious Studies Department.
Professor Khawaja teaches
in the religion and modernity
area of religious studies,
working at the intersection of philosophy,
religious thought, and culture
in the modern Euro-Americas.
Her work deals with social
practices of authenticity
and with the effects and concepts
that structure our experience of the real.
In fact, I think this is FX
and concepts that structure
our experience of the real.
Okay, thank you so much,
Professor Khawaja, and welcome.
- Thank you so much for the
inviting me to be on this panel.
I've already learned a great deal
from all those who've spoken
and it is a very exciting opportunity
to talk about these things.
I think, in the interest
of not repeating some
of those in the panel
who've already gone
and who've said things that I agree with,
I'll say that referring back
to a few of those comments,
I think...
Well, I'll start by saying,
I speak not as an in any way an expert
on artificial intelligence, or technology,
or the history of technology in any way,
and I speak also as a teacher
at a particular kind of university
that we are all inhabiting.
It's not the same how we might
approach these questions,
I think for Yale undergraduate
students, for example,
than if we were teaching
at a larger public school
with a different kind
of student population,
and perhaps, because of that,
perhaps, because of the
kinds of things I teach
in the humanities,
the questions about
checking for cheating
and that sort of thing,
I think play a little
bit of a different role
in the way that I think
about these questions.
It doesn't track, I think,
alongside some of those
who've spoken already,
it doesn't track with some of the way
that the headlines are framing the issues,
especially, I think,
difficult to talk about
are two aspects.
One is to do, I think, with
the broader era that we're in.
We've been here before is
one of the themes I think
that people have been mentioning,
and that's so both in the sense
of a particular panic about
a particular kind of tool,
which will introduce
particular possibilities
which we can't totally map at present
and the kind of anxiety
that builds around that particular event,
but then a kind of broader anxiety,
which I think we're seeing
in so many different registers
of social life today,
which is kind of an ontological confusion.
What's real, what's mine, what's yours?
How the kinds of knowledges
that we practice are made.
There's a lot of...
I think the conversations
that we're having about AI
are maybe particular condensations
of a lot of the conversations
that we've been having
about facts and fictions,
and the very fact that
all these different kinds of tools
that we might describe as AI,
people who've worked on the
meaning of that category,
but just so far as we are
talking about it for ourselves
as a potential learning tool
and even in other cases,
a potential learning obstacle, I think,
more thinking about what it means
to designate it as artificial
is really warranted
and what it means to group a
lot of these tools together
as some kind of thing
that's different than
the normal way we learn.
Because, as Professor
Wexler's comments indicated,
all the way back to writing
is an initial practice
that we might think about as a technology
which dramatically
changed the way we think,
and communicate, and understand ourselves,
and so breaking apart that
category of artificial
and thinking through it a
little bit more granularly,
and where some of these
deeper conversations
that we're having in lots
of areas of our culture
are maybe feeding this,
and less focused, perhaps,
on the particulars.
This one area
that I think would be really
beneficial for students
and for faculty as well,
but the flip side of that is,
in fact, I think we do need a
lot more particular knowledge
about the specific tools,
but not so much...
Not only or not not limited
to the way in which the
algorithms work or don't work,
and not only limited to the degree
to which we can detect particular forms
of bias circulating in them,
but this is a perspective that I learned
from colleagues who work
in this field of history
of science and technology.
The kind of work that I
know about from them is
so focused on questions of how
technological tools are made.
Who pays for them?
What interests are involved
in the construction of them?
How our own engagement with them benefits
the potential projects
that may be in development,
and all of those kinds of questions
are so essential to knowing
how we would be able to
actually use the tool,
almost like really
detailed social biographies
of particular tools we might be using.
That seems like something that
would be essential to have,
and, I think, the
difficulties in doing that
are both what some people
have already mentioned
about the corporate interests
and how accessible all that information is
to the public eye,
and the fact that these
are often corporations
who are running them.
That's not been given
that we would have access
to that kind of information.
Excuse me.
But also, I think something
that's making that difficult is
simply the pace
at which these particular
tools are developing,
and so, what would that mean to do that
for each example,
and each genre of artificial intelligence
that's going to be
inundating us in the coming,
however many years that
this boom is happening?
And so, what would that mean
to do that in each case?
It really does seem to me
that a required course
in history of technology,
history and sociology of technology,
would need to be something
that the university should think about,
so that everyone would feel that...
Before we know how we
even wanna talk about
what creativity means,
or what originality means,
or what cheating would even mean
in relation to a tool like that,
which is not at all clear,
we have a sense of what
it is we're dealing with
in a really academic,
scholarly rich sense,
and at present, that doesn't
seem to be widely available.
So that's kind of where I'm coming from.
- Thank you so much, Professor Khawaja,
and all the panelists,
we're gonna spend 25 minutes
hashing this out further,
but I feel like there's so
much to think about already.
Even if we all just went off and wrote,
we would get a lot further
than we'd been alone.
I'm gonna make one very
sweeping observation,
which everyone in the
audience might not need,
but I just feel some
pressure as the moderator
to say something like this.
So we got a lot of
questions during the chat
and I'm gonna bring up
as many of them as I can,
but I noticed that some of them refer back
to a distinction or separation
that Professor Vishnoi
always started us with,
which is the space between
evaluation and learning.
In the middle of the panel,
we talked a lot about
the opportunities for learning and growth,
and T newness that this
technology opens up,
and how can we seize those
by approaching it with a certain mindset.
So I'd say these are two,
and then the third,
which I think Professor Khawaja spoke
to the most directly is
what she called the
ontological uncertainty
of these things happening
at this particular historical moment
with our particular social,
cultural, economic structures,
and so I'm just noticing
those three as big themes
that if this were a classroom,
we were gonna write a paper,
I'd say, "Pick one of these
three themes and do X,"
and then you'd submit it.
No, I won't make a ChatGPT joke.
So with that said,
I'm gonna start with one or
two questions that came in
that are a little bit
more simple and concrete,
because I think there are ways,
and we didn't end up talking about them,
but we'll see.
I mentioned this to the panel in advance.
I'm hoping, even if you
don't feel like an expert,
that one or at most two people
will take a swing at
some of these questions,
and so the first one actually
came in ahead of the panel
and it may seem like
it doesn't really fit,
but I think it's very important.
It's essentially about evaluation
and it's about...
We talked about practices for teaching
and how they might have to change,
and we talked about understanding
this moment more deeply
so that students could
direct their own change,
but one piece of take home writing
that the university relies
on in a processing way
are application essays,
especially, for graduate school,
and so one of the
questions that came in is,
are there practices or ways
that we could think profitably about
using application essays
for professional schools like
medical school and law school?
And we didn't really talk about that,
because I think, appropriately,
we were thinking about teaching
from the moment of, students are with us,
but I wonder if anyone
wants to start with that
and then I'll just say,
who wants to do a follow up?
And then we'll go on to another question.
- [Justin] Alfie, can you
expand on that a little bit?
- Oh, absolutely, Justin.
Thank you very
- Yeah, just what you mean--
- I guess...
How I understand the question is,
once students are here,
we can do things with their
engagement with software
like this.
You gave some very
powerful, concrete examples
of ways you can have
students look at the output
and do critical reading
as a way of learning more.
We can talk to them about the difference
between what the machine can produce
and what some students
in the class can produce,
and help them strive for that,
but when students are
submitting things to us
that they've produced at home
before they're even students
and it's hard for us to
tell to what degree they did
or did not collaborate with AI,
are there any practices or
ways that we could think about
either how to feel or read those materials
or are there different ways we
could ask questions of people
who are applying to come to Yale,
than essentially, "Send
us a take home essay,
answer this question that
we've crafted for you?"
That's where I think
the question comes from
and I think it's a work process anxiety.
There's a thing thing we do.
It takes a lot of time.
It's an important part
of how we get our students here on campus
and it seems that this technology
will immediately disrupt it.
So I don't know if anyone
on the panel feels like
you even just want to give
us a mantra to think about,
if not practice,
but it seems like a fair question to me.
What about the materials
that come before we even
have the students with us,
so that we can engage them differently?
Yeah, Professor Wexler.
- Well, isn't this a
question of evaluation?
Isn't this the same
And I hesitate, since it's
really a very time consuming,
professional activity,
and I'm not doing it to
make a statement about it,
but the further philosophical question is,
evaluating for what?
We really have now to know
what the purpose of these years
that we wanna spend with
the applicants would be.
Evaluating for what?
And I do think this is disruptive.
There are many opportunities
for disruption.
I would hesitate to say what they are,
but evaluation is one of the terms
that comes under pressure.
What for?
Did people need to learn to
add, and subtract, and multiply,
or was the slide rule fine?
Did people need to learn
to write their own application to college
or was learning to use chat AI fine?
And if it was fine, what do we
do with them when they come?
What is it for that they
would be here with us?
We need to talk about that.
- Yeah, that's great,
and Professor Farrell,
I think you're offered to
speak back to this too.
- Yeah, I just wanted to
build on Professor Wexler
just very quickly,
in the sense of,
I think this is a question of evaluation,
but I think it's part
of a broader emphasis,
or at least where we're moving is
not relying on one indicator,
whether it's the essay or GRE scores,
but a holistic evaluation of
what the student is bringing,
what the university can
offer them as a person,
what our community can provide them
as they learn with other
students in community.
That's really important as well,
and then obviously
letters of recommendation,
but hopefully those aren't
written by AI as well.
Then I don't know.
(Justin laughing)
- Professor Khawaja, I
see you have your hand up.
- I do confess that that
was the silent thought
that crossed my mind when we
were reading all the headlines
about students using ChatGPT was,
what about the recommendation side?
But I also wanna build
on the last two comments.
I think that maybe this is...
I don't know how this point will go over,
but at the undergraduate level,
obviously, faculty are not at
all involved in admissions.
It's a complete black box.
At the PhD level,
which is all that religious
studies operates at,
we don't operate in an MA,
I think it's very unlikely
that we would have that kind of an issue
with someone submitting the
kind of extended research
that you would need
to apply to a PhD program
in the humanities,
but at the undergraduate level,
just to take the spirit
of your question on,
I think, thinking back to
something Professor Vishnoi said
about the use of AI,
one of the positive potential
uses of this kind of thing is
when there is a very distinct norm
that others are being
asked to follow or to meet,
because what we're looking
at is a norm machine,
like, a patterned repetition of norms
that are already flowing through
whatever they're being fed.
That can be a very effective way,
and as a faculty concerned about access
and some of these other things
that we talk about today,
and equity in the university,
it could be a wonderful thing in a way
if admissions essays were a
little bit more randomized,
if like applications were a
little bit more randomized
at the admissions level.
I don't think that would
necessarily be a bad thing.
I would much rather be talking about
what we would use it for in a classroom
or what kind of a tool it would be
than how we would prevent people
from using it to get into the university.
That could be an interesting hack.
- Yeah, Professor Vishnoi.
- So I just wanted to add
to what Noreen just said.
I think it immediately means
that we have to diversify our evaluation.
I think what also happens
in these kinds of places,
such as where we are right now, is that,
over time, the evaluation
process has become very stylized
and started benefiting
those who have access
and privilege to all the resources,
and I think this in general is a bad thing
as far as I'm concerned,
and so perhaps we need to
just diversify evaluations,
and I think what Noreen is saying,
that we have to get used to
reading more diverse essays,
as opposed to all essays
having a very similar flavor,
and if one of these essays comes
from outside, it feels odd,
and so our tendency is to reject
it or devalue it some way.
So I think it also helps...
I think, at the end of the day,
we as evaluators
will also have to correct
our internal biases.
What exactly are we responding
to with theses essays,
is it content or the style?
And I think that's a challenge for us.
- And I wanna acknowledge,
Professor Vishnoi,
that you said something like this
in your example of the student
trying to write an email
who might be writing in
their second language,
that it's an evener.
So we have a couple of
other specific questions
that I will get to in a moment,
but I wanna make sure
we ask one other person
to prepare for this event,
and it's a student...
We call it a respondent,
but she's not necessarily
gonna respond to all of you,
but her name is Isiuwa Omoigui,
and I'm gonna introduce her now.
Isiuwa Omoigui is a
senior in Yale College,
majoring in political science.
Originally from Los Angeles,
she serves as a lead writing
partner at the Poorvu Center
and has been involved
with the Afro-American Cultural Center,
Yale's undergraduate
political journal, and more,
and we're gonna ask
her just to speak to us
just for a few moments about...
I'll let you say where
you're speaking from, Isiuwa.
- Sure, thank you so much for
the thoughtful introduction.
So first and foremost,
it's really been a pleasure
just to hear the perspective
of so many different distinguished faculty
and to to be in conversation with you all.
So I think that the conversation
that we're having here
and around the country about ChatGPT is
really both a challenge and an opportunity
to think deeper and more critically
about what we do at the university
as students and as educators, and why,
and it's definitely true
that concerns about academic
dishonesty are warranted,
but ultimately we do what
we do here as students,
not just to gain credentials
or to get a grade on a transcript,
but really to learn how to think, to read,
and to solve problems after we leave Yale,
and so borrowing from what
Professor Wexler said earlier,
striving for the reality of learning,
rather than just its appearance is
really what matters to me,
and I think a lot of my peers would agree.
So I think, with that in mind,
the critical work is to figure out
how to responsibly engage
with the technology as a tool,
rather than a crutch,
because tech is
really an increasingly
important part of the world
that we live in,
and our everyday lives,
especially, as a 21st century student,
I feel they need to know
how to engage with this kind
of technology responsibly
and understand it's
limits and it's biases,
which Professor Vishnoi spoke to earlier.
Some faculty at other universities
have proposed using ChatGPT
to represent one side of
a debate for instance,
and then having students
dialogue with that.
So I still believe that
there's room for us
to engage with this
responsibly in the classroom
while still maintaining the development
of those critical thinking skills
that technology alone
shouldn't take the place of,
but all in all,
I'm really excited about the changes
that our engagement with
ChatGPT will inspire.
So rethinking how we understand
learning and evaluation,
creating more opportunities
for experiential learning
and problem-based learning.
So, ultimately, I think staying true
to our broader mission of learning
and receiving an education
to go out into the
world and solve problems
should remain at the heart of what we do,
but really the opportunity here is,
to learn how to work with the technology,
understand what it can't do,
and build those critical skills
and creativity that we'll need
to take with us once we
leave the university.
- Thank you so much, Isiuwa.
I'm gonna take one piece of what you said
and offer it as a question,
but the panel, please feel
free to speak back in any way
to the concerns and, I'd say,
hopes that Isiuwa was expressing.
So you mentioned an example, Isiuwa,
of using ChatGPT to set up a debate
so that students could engage in dialogue
and try to represent the other side,
and we've heard a couple of other examples
of specific things people
might do using this tool.
I'll just say,
I have about a dozen questions
on my desk in front of me
and four or five of them are,
"Could people give some
more concrete examples
of ways we might actually
try to work with this tool
and not against it?"
I understand there may be more
deep learning we have to do
to make those choices well,
but I wonder if anyone
on the panel is willing
to just generate,
for instance, if a year from now,
we realize, "Oh, that
was the wrong way to go,"
well, at least you gave
us somewhere to start.
- Yeah, so on my syllabus this semester,
it's a requirement for
students to use ChatGPT
to answer their research questions,
and so they have a couple
weeks to work with it
and then they write an essay
that's responding to
their research question,
and then they have
ChatGPT as much as it can,
and just critique it in a very basic way
in the ways that I mentioned.
I have a second assignment
that I'm gonna introduce
on the commodification
of these sorts of tools,
and so thinking critically
about those sorts of interests as well.
So, very basic.
- So I'll offer two examples up.
One of the things
that we often try to train
our students to do is
to differentiate the
hype about a technology
from the reality of the technology,
and ChatGPT is a fantastic example there
where you can look at the headlines
and what is claimed about it,
and then actually work with
the real system directly,
which is not often something
that in many cases you're able to do,
and explore the boundaries yourself,
and especially, as we're
trying to build students
who are really informed
about the limits of
where technology can go
and what the likely implications
of that technology are,
being able to seek out and
find that critique on your own,
is a really fantastic experience.
So we often like to pair
the claims about GPT
with the experience of GPT
as a great learning tool.
The second thing that we often use it for,
honestly, is to address questions
about the role of the technology
and issues related to the
responsibility of authorship.
I saw just last week
that science and nature came
out with two guiding rules
about how to use ChatGPT
in similar large language
models in scientific papers,
and it was very simple.
It was number one if you use them at all,
that you must acknowledge them,
and that seems to be a very easy thing
for everyone to understand,
but their second rule was that ChatGPT
and similar models can never
be listed as an author,
and the why for that I think is
a really great lesson for us,
and the thing that they
very explicitly said
in their announcement
was that with authorship
comes a responsibility
and that none of those language models,
none of those technologies could
accept that responsibility,
and so thinking about that in that way
actually lets us get at some issues about,
what does it mean for these
systems to produce materials?
Do we allow them to be copywritten?
Do we allow them to have authorship?
Should we allow them to...
Are they due royalties?
Should we have robots that work pay taxes?
There's a lot of questions about this
that are both at a technology
level and a policy level
that are deep and rich,
and this is a great way to approach them.
- Oh, thank you very much.
That was very helpful.
We are gonna use all our
remaining eight minutes,
I just wanted to tell you that,
but we're gonna put in
the chat now a link.
If you feel able to multitask,
I'm gonna ask you to give us this.
It's an invitation both
to give some feedback
and to raise questions
that you want the Poorvu Center
and / or other people
we would ask to help us
continue to work on, continue to develop.
I'll mention a very specific question
that came in to us in advance
just as an example was,
would the Poorvu Center host a session
in which faculty members
who hadn't tried it before
could try ChatGPT and get tips,
and try another version of it,
and then discuss the results,
and we might do that exact thing,
in which case,
I don't know if we'll give authorship
to the person who suggested it or not,
but we'll certainly do things like that.
So I just wanna say
that we'd love any other kinds of feedback
that you can give us.
If you don't do it in
the next seven minutes,
everyone who's registered for this event
will get it as a link in
a follow up email as well,
but I think it's obvious that we listen
to what everyone out there
is thinking and saying,
and so it's also anonymous by the way.
You don't have to include
your contact information
unless you want to.
It's very explicitly
in a separate question,
and then most of my goal here,
which has very well been achieved,
is not to offer anything on my own,
because you're all doing so amazing,
but I'm just gonna mention something,
and if people in the English
department want to be upset
that I represented this,
I apologize,
but there's a thing that English 120,
which is a specific course at Yale,
that a lot of students take,
calls close reading for craft,
and it puts in the foreground
of teaching writing, looking at texts,
and thinking about how they work,
and which things are worth emulating
and where you want to
exceed or change them,
and I'll just say in my
own tiny, little class
of only 12 first years this year,
I gave ChatGPT one of
the homework assignments,
and we looked at the example together,
and talked about,
what is it doing that you thought
was one of the things you needed to do
and what is it not doing
that you even writing
it for the first time,
this kind of assignment,
you sensed needed to be done?
And how could I write this assignment,
so that it would ask you for more of that
and less of the first?
And then we had a discussion,
and I'm not saying we achieved it.
And like I said, that may
turn out to have been naive,
but it's a really specific example.
It wasn't even debating with the model.
It was looking at it as a
piece of language constructed
and then thinking about, what can it do?
I really just mean that as an example.
If one occurs to me from this page,
I'll pop one more question in there,
but I think what I'd like to say is,
some of you didn't respond
to questions during the question period,
and is there something
that you were thinking
during the rest of the panel
or some last word you want to
give us, our last question,
just to give you one more
shot to say something?
I'm speaking to the panelists here.
- I just wanna say, in the materials
that Jenny Frederick put
on the Poorvu website,
there was one person
who said that her dream
was that her university
would make a week available
for faculty to go to computer camp.
(Laura laughing)
And let us learn together.
I thought that was a great idea.
- I'm gonna add a reflection on...
I'm gonna say it's on what
Professor Khawaja was discussing,
although there was a buildup.
Since she synthesized a little bit,
there was a buildup to it,
but I'm thinking about
how I have to take some...
Maybe I don't have to do anything,
maybe I don't need to overreact,
but I'm doing some actions
in relationship with this new technology
while trying to understand
the historical moment,
and I don't know if you have
any advice on how to pause
or what a pattern of act
and reflect might look like,
but this is a thing I
find myself anxious about.
So turning to you.
- There is no pause, not in Yale,
and not in the world that Yale
is feeding and be fed from,
but if we were really
serious about doing it,
we would make one.
We would make that week.
We would make that pause.
We would require the class
that maybe doesn't teach the details
of how a particular technological entity
that we're dealing with is made,
but teaches at a minimum,
students how to ask the questions
that they would need to know
and where to look for
that kind of information.
Us as well, I think we'd
probably need a computer camp
and also a history of
tech camp for all of us.
- Professor Scassellati.
- So I will add two things to that.
One quickly is just that
the dean's office actually has a series
of small, by faculty for faculty classes
at the end of the year,
and over the last three years,
we have offered an AI for faculty
or a natural language for faculty course.
So we are actually hoping
to try to address that in many ways
and we've been also struggling
to try to find a way
to address this systemically
at the undergraduate level,
because we see AI tools coming out
that are impacting every
possible area of inquiry
in ways that we cannot anticipate,
and in many cases,
did not even guess at in
the years ahead of time.
So starting next year,
we're hoping to offer an
AI course for non-majors
with no programming required,
and look for more details
on that hopefully soon.
I'm hoping that it gets approved.
The last thing I would say is
that we've talked a lot about
what are the boundary cases and places
where we don't think that this
technology would be useful,
but reflecting back on the announcements
from science and nature,
they acknowledged the case
that there were very good, potential uses
for this technology,
and not only as...
Nisheeth had mentioned
that this was a way of leveling the field,
but that there may be genuinely
good places to use this.
So I think one of the challenging
questions I'm left with
after this panel is,
what are the places
where we would want the
use of this technology
in our courses?
What are the positive cases
where that would be seen
as a very useful addition
and can we define some rules
and some boundary cases
to say that beyond that is
maybe not what we want to see?
So maybe we can come up
with some of those as well.
- I have to say, I love going
out on a potential high note.
So thank you for making me
feel a little more cheerful.
Thank you so much to the panel.
I feel really moved and daunted
by your wisdom and care about this,
and thank you for
everyone who came to show
that you wanna learn more about this,
and do best by our
students and our culture.
So that's it for today.
We will be following up with other events
and we're very grateful to everyone.
Take care.
(upbeat music)